c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
alors la première photo je pense que
c'est gégé parce qu'elle kiffe le sport
la deuxième je pense que c'est je pense
que c'est jean mimi qui fait croire
qu'il y des livres et la troisième
je pense que c'est mathieu parce qu'il a
un humour pour y est écrit clochard sur
le truc donc je pense que c'est mathieu
à merde
dans l'ordre je dirais
kelly non non non non pas du tout je
dirais benji parce qu'il a été à l'expo
on me semble je dirais bernard parce
qu'il est totalement fan de kelly donc
même quand elle fait la grimace et tout
lui poste il s'en fout et après kelly
parce que évidemment elle est fan de
licorne
j'ai bon amère maxine abba maxime tous
pareils il adore les licornes away ah
ben merde
ah ben non alors je sais je sais ça
c'est bouder c'est ludivine et face à
castaldi c'est tout faux
[Musique]